vor einem Monat ist in Thailand ein
nachtboot mit 70 Touristen an Bord
gesunken es wurden alle gerettet die
Boote sind uralt und das passiert da
halt mal wenn es etwas stürmischer ist
genau dasselbe Boot auf der gleichen
Route habe ich mir gebucht also nicht
mehr genau das gleiche weil das liegt
jetzt am Boden aber halt ein Kollegen
davon der genauso aussieht um von der
Insel kotao wieder ans festern zu
gelangen ich habe noch nie zuvor auf
einem Boot übernachtet deshalb war ich
umso gespannter bevor es losging mussten
wir uns erstmal bei dieser Frau melden
die uns dann das Ticket überreicht hat
eigentlich meinte sie wir haben Glück es
sind nur wenige Leute an Bord ja so war
dann der erste Eindruck an Bord unten
sind ir welche Leute die da arbeiten und
oben liegen dann ungefähr 100 Matten wo
man sich eine aussuchen kann alles
natürlich sehr sehr einfach eingerichtet
erst waren wir wirklich nur so
15entouris an Bord kurz vor Abfahrt
kamen dann aber locker noch mal 80
Locals dazu und das Boot war proppevoll
eigentlich ja gar kein Problem würden
die nicht alle die ganze Nacht auf ihren
Handys rumbimmeln und die auf volle
Lautstärke stellen aber das stört da
anscheinend kein geschlafen habe ich
aber trotzdem ganz gut ich war danach
nur ziemlich erkältet sonst war es eine
lustige Erfahrung und für 18 € pris okay
muss ich jetztich noch mal machen aber
was meint ihr für weitere